[音楽]
っと
see why me
[音楽]
ゲイベラシェア僕のすごく好きな言葉です
まあ日本語ではとりあえず挑戦してみようっていうことなんですけれども皆さんどれ
ぐらいチャレンジしているでしょうか
今年の4月にですねえっこういうメッセージをいただきました
慶應義塾大学環境情報学部3年
小西優花と申します本日7月15日に sfc で開催するテックス kous sc
give らしゃーてにご登壇お願いしたくご連絡させていただきました
突然のお願い時
恐縮ですがぜひ30分ほど忙しい場合5分10分でも構いませんので記者にご訪問させ
ていただけないでしょうかというメッセージいただけました
僕自身もですね会いたい人にこのようなメールを送ったり
会いたい人に直接会いに行ったりして自分で行動していろんな活動をしてきました
今日さんからこのメールをいただいたことによってですね
どうやったら行動することができるのか今まで自分が築いてきたことを皆さんとシェア
したいと思って本日ここに熱いトークをさせいただきたいと思います
まず行動が人を動かす僕はですね行動するということをテーマに毎日明るく元気よく
活動してます
ただ
今ずーっとそうだというわけではなくて僕も昔悩んでいてその一歩を進めることができ
なかった時期がありました
これがですねあの約10年前の僕です左側ですね色んな事に悩んでまして
こういうことをすればいいのかなとかこういうことしたら他の人がどう思うのかなとか
自分って一体何ができるのかなということですごく悩んでました
ずーっと悩んでますとどうなるか悩むことに飽きたんですね
また今日悩むのかとでいろんな本を読んだりしてみて気づいたのがいろんな経営者の人
たちは行動をしたり失敗を自分たちで克服したりしているのでじゃあ実際そういう人
たちに会って話し聞いたら面白いんじゃないかなと思い
まして10年前に私の哲学というインタビューサイトを立ち上げました
これは自分が
好きな人に直接連絡をしてすいません会いたいんですけどちょっと時間作っていただけ
ませんかと
この企画が始まる前までは自分と正社員とかを連れて話をしてたんですけれども
すごくいい話がいっぱいあるのでじゃあ web で公開しようと思って
11年続けています
最近ではのファッションデザイナーのドン小西さんとか
建築家の隈研吾先生とかあとプロゴルファーの青木さんとかいろんな方があの人の紹介
とかですね
10年も続けているのっていうことで色々と快諾していただけまして
自分の絵人脈とか色々ネタを吸収して
紹介するっていうことを続けてきています
で10年やっているとですねこの形のある特徴とかどういって傾向があるのかという
ことを知ることができました
11弾やって気づいたことみんな元気な大人です
子供の時元気な子供いると思いますけれども大人になっても元気に活動しているという
ことが特徴的でした
二つ目は遊び心があるということです
人生楽しむということですね
で3つ目が旅をして見識を高めているということです
同じ場所にいるんではなくて新しいものを見に行く
自分が今いる快適なゾーンから出るっていう事をしていますこれが特徴なんですけれど
もどういった力
共通する要素っていうものがあるのかっていうのを
年間この方と会ったらこういうこと言ったなとかこういうことを結構面白かったなと
いうことを分析するとですね
ある力があることに気づきました
この6つの力です
この6つの子からというのがこれまで取材させていただいた方や仕事で会う経営者
ビジネスパートナーたちの行動ですね分析してますと一つ目に一番必要なのが元気力な
んですね
本当に元気だっていうことだけで色々と人生て切り開くことができます
例えば仕事をお願いする時にフライフとにお願いするとか
明るい人にお願いするのかっていうとも明る人にお願いすると思うんですねその次に
行動力なんです
行動してますいうよりもまず実行っていう傾向を
いいですで行動することによって彼らに備わる力っていうのがこの木軌道修正力なん
ですね自分の軌道修正をする必要がないということはほとんど行動していないっていう
ことを意味しますので何か起きた時にやばいなぁと何か考えなきゃいけない
ちょっと困ったら誰かに
頼まなきゃいけないということがこの軌道修正力になります
4つ目が学習能力です1回何か失敗したら次どういうふうに生かすことができるか
また新しい知識とか新しいサービスがあったらそれを学ぶ姿勢
そして週間力です
今から歯を磨く前って言って歯を磨く人は多分そんなにないと思うんですね
習慣になっているので出ました自分に行かなきゃーとか
ダイエットしなきゃっていうのはまだ習慣化されてないのですごく意識する必要がある
んです
ずーっと同じことを繰り返して習慣化させることによって
自分の一部になっていくんですね最終的に自分が今何とかいろんなことが起きたときに
変化ができるかということがこれまでインタビューして気付いたことですじゃあ皆さん
もじゃあこういう力を身につけるためにはどうすればいいか
ちょっとある例をご説明したいと思います亀とウサギが戦う場合になった時よく
いろんな物語であると思うんですけれども同じ陸で勝負しようと思うと多分亀が負け
ちゃうと思うんですねでも日目の特徴を考えた時に
日目は体がすごく硬いとかあっ
とはある空のが遅いけれども泳ぐっていう力があります
泳ぐことができればあとは長生きできるという特徴もあります
ってことうさぎと戦う時に走るレースではなくて泳ぐレースだったりとか
長い距離のまあ年数のレースあれば壁も勝つ可能性があるわけですね
皆さんにも個性があるわけです自分の個性っていうのを知って自分の戦う場所を間違え
ないということがすごく大事なことになります
まず自分を知るということです
でもじゃあ自分を知らない場合どうするのかということは
探すことなんですね
僕は人生ですごくマジックワードっていうのがイエスだと思ってます
何かあった時に自分から yes っていう風に言うことによっていろいろと奇跡が
起きてます僕はこの10年間今回のあのプレゼンをするときにどういうことをしてきた
なということであのなんかバイクの免許いいよてことで
あの大型バイクを取ってバイクの免許取れましたでスパルタンレースって言う泥に
まみれて走るレースがあるんですけれども日本に来てから走ってみようとか
あとは体を鍛えるとメンタルも強くなるよということでゴールド主婦にズって来はじめ
まして
トライアスロンをやると体力つけようと
要するに自分の限界を超えることができるということでチャレンジしました
そして流用区でハロウィンの仮装大会からやろうよと
をやってみましょうた
また多くの人と会うことができますそしてカラーランというゴキローの
楽しく走るレースとかホノルルマラソン走ってみたいなあっていう人多いので自分も
走ってみようってことを走ってみましたフルマラソンを走ると本当に我慢しなきゃいけ
ないということを知りましたし
フィリピンの方では台風があったので者義援活動として直接フィリピンに物資を届けに
行こうって行動したいですね
あと a レスのアイスバケットチャレンジっていうのがありましたのでそれに向けて
あの
まあ氷が冷たいということも知ったりとかって先輩が船に乗れると世界に行けるぞと
いうことで
船舶
勉強をとってお台場をクルージングしたりとか
ボクシング一回行ってみたいなということで牧神をやってやっぱサーフィンでしょう
人生はっていう先輩もいるので色々試してみました
で皆さんもフォア経営者とか僕の周りの人達っていうのはやっぱり元気な方が多いので
遊び心っていうのはすごくあるんですね
で僕は誰かのモノマネをするよりもまず自分のスキルって何なのか自分がどういうこと
をやるのが好きなのかでその自分の地図を常にアップデートすることがすごく大事なん
ですね
バイクをやればバイクの友達もできますしサーフィンをやったらサーフィンの中もでき
ますし
自分の地図をアップデートするということは新しいことをしない限りは知ることができ
ないんですね何かに向いているか向いてないかっていうのはやってみない限りわかん
ないわけです
やる前から向いてないとかや私なんてでは
なくてやるということがすごく大切なんです
で僕はあのインタビューいろんなことしてますですね結構面白い話がありましてこれ
野生のカモンっていう話をするみなさんにシェアしたいと思います
鴨は渡り鳥で結構1000キロぐらいブラーたコブラシーンですねである湖の方につい
てそこでへさぁ
がありますそこを食べて本当だとりあえずなくなったらもう1回飛ぶわけです
ただこの渡り鳥たちっていうのはあのある場所に行ったらおじいさんがですね餌を
くれるスを可愛いなーってご飯ふえっ
朝昼晩くれます
でずっと自分たちも飛ばなくてもそこの場所で餌をもらうことができるので飛ばなく
なってしまったんですね
3年くらいずっとそれをやっていたらおじいさんが死んじゃったんです
そうするぞやばい餌を食べることができない
どうしようじゃ飛ぼうと思っても飛べなくなってしまったんです
安定した場所にいて
ご飯ももらって天敵もいなく守られている環境にずっといたんですね
それで雪が解けてワーッと流れてきて飛べなかった
矢田もが死んじゃったというストーリーなんです
でもうこれすごく面白いなと思ったのがひとつの場所にずっと安定してしまうと考える
力とか自分が本来持ってた力っていうのはなくなるんですねまぁ大学生とかで言ったら
高校3年生の時に受験しようと思って学力一番高くて就職活動する月に落ちてるみたい
なこともあると思うんですけど
もう安定することによって自分の力というのはどんどん落ちていくんですね
だから殻を破るということがいかに必要か
4羽のカラスがいいますそのうちのカラスの位置はが俺はこんなとこから飛び降りて
やるぜ
こんな枝に立ってる場合じゃないって言ったわけです
1時間くらい経ったらまた戻るんですけれども
4羽のカラスはまだそこにいるわけです
なぜかと言いますとこの一羽のカラスは
飛び降りるっていうふうに決心しただけなんですね
すごい大事なポイントで結審するということと報道するっていうことはすごい差がある
んです
勉強しようっていうふうに決めて
やった決心したっていう人いるんですけども大事なのは
決心した後にいかに報道ができるかなんです
好きな人がいたら好きだって言わない限りは伝わらないんです
これを僕的にですね10年のに当てて
gdd 最中ぶるるなんですけれどもこれはよくあの pdca とかまあ色々として
はありますけれども僕は一番大事なのはこのデュールるーなんです
なんだこの10 do で大事かっていうのは do することによって絶対考え
いいますか考えようって言って考えるじゃ何かをすれば考えるんです
何かをすれば困ったなぁと思って次の手段を考えるわけですよ
るーるーですもっとこれができるようになると
true っていう風になれます do ができるかどうかということがポイントです
できるだけデュオ増やす
ことなんですね
でこれなぜこの do がいいかと言いますか
今回のテーマなんですけれどもルールっていう言葉があります
一番好きな言葉なんですけれども do に er がついてるんですよまあ人のこと
を指すんですけれども
まあ日本語で言うとは行動する人をやる人
これ重要です
で反対の人はなんていうかドンチャーリー2
デュー黒いとドンとしていないんです
僕は色々とまぁこの10年間インタビューしたいとかこの人取材したいねっていうので
いつも会うときにこの子はどういうタイプなのかなってこの人は行動力があるかなとか
軌道修正能力があるかなとか色々調べるんですけれども
そこで世の中には二通りの人しかいないんですねもう
10 r 香呑町なんですやる人なのかやらない人なのか
これいつの時代でもこれは言えることなんです
確率論キノコでるんですけどもたとえちゃん犬っていうのに勝ち続けたければ
とりあえずやることなんですね
例えばすいませんちょっとジャンキーができます勝って負けましたでまた一週間後に
行っても行ってお願い出来ますかっていうよりも
とりあえずじゃんけんかなりやることによって確率が高まってくるわけです
行動の量を増やすことによって
自分の成功確率でも高まってきます
間違いだとしてもそこで間違えたっていうことが言えるんですね
ですからデュー頃になることによって最初の一歩というのはすごく難しいかもしれない
んですけれどもそれを習慣化させることが出来ればこんな面白いことがあったんだ
こういう新しい気づきがあったんだということは気づくことができます
でこれすごく面白いんですけれども今までいろんな方とかってですねその僕はできるん
だって愛犬流 s とかできない
archi 偏流ですとか言う人は書いてあってるんですね
自分ができると思った人絶対にできていますしできないって言っている人はほとんど
できないと
で僕は何でこういうふうに行動するようになったかというのは高校3年生の時にですね
魚屋でアルバイトしてアワビを食べてアナフィラキシーショック状態っていうんだって
死にかけたんですね
で1日で7キロ痩せてなんか視覚神経がやられて目が見えなくなってですね
そこではああやばい人生一度キーなんだと
でいろんなまあその後住職とかにあったらですね
次はさんに言えることは一つです
市は保証されてますって言われたんですよ
ですから皆さんに対しても同じことです行動できるかっていうことを保証できないです
けれども
全員こんなか皆死んじゃうんですそれはもう事実なんですね
ですから c 階はすべてかすり傷になりますので今自分がその残されている時間って
いうものを悩んでたり
校
報道しなかったらすごくもったいないんですね
小学校の時に永六輔さんと対談でお会いしたことあるんですけどもあの講演会でですね
朝起きた時にきょうは15日7月15日2018年の7月15日
この広い宇宙の中で2018年7月15日は1日しかないから
力いっぱい器用っていう風に言うらしいです
その時は協定1日しかないんだっていうことを意識することができました
僕は行動するということはほんの小さなことでいいと思います
自分に自信を持つということは行動することの結果なんですね
ですから今日参加していただいた皆さんに何らかのヒントになれば凄く嬉しいんです
けれども
一番大事なにょなのは行動するということです
自分自身を持って
行動するということです
芸名ラッシュアありがとうございました
[拍手]